this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
what's up wisecrack michael here i don't
know if you knew this but a lot of
people are having
totally level-headed reason debates
about censorship these days
we are we are living under well when are
living for that
effect under communist regime right now
we're living under a nazi regime a
communist regime a fascist regime
just kidding youtube removes videos for
spreading medical misinformation
tick-tock shadow bans certain political
content university professors are
losing their jobs and it seems like
every week facebook and reddit are
banning
entire communities that violate their
terms of service as for the government
civil rights lawyers accuse the u.s
military of violating the first
amendment for banning users on their
twitch streams who ask them about war
crimes
and then you know there's this
[Music]
a lot of it raises a central question
what is censorship
am i being unjustly censored when i get
thrown out of my local taco bell after
smearing myself in mashed potatoes to
protest their anti-spud menu changes
what about if i do it at city hall more
seriously
we might ask about what it means when
private entities who have always had a
right to refuse people's service for
many
but not all reasons get the fact check a
public figure
or block people from sharing a news
article about the son of a presidential
candidate
americans like to celebrate our long
history free expression
and as a result we really hate when
something looks or even just
feels like censorship but it turns out
the way we think about censorship is
often wrong
and usually inadequate for thinking
about what it looks like today
to figure out what the is happening
let's go back to the beginning in this
wisecrack edition on
and before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to keeps
it can be really embarrassing to talk
about getting older it seems like your
back is always out of whack you don't
recognize all the memes on twitter
and some people might find themselves
losing their hair
in fact two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35.
unfortunately you can't just urban
dictionary away the solution to losing
your hair however
you can turn to keeps keeps is an
affordable hair loss treatment program
that provides fda approved prescription
and over-the-counter medication
you used to have to go to the doctor's
office for a hair loss prescription but
thanks to
keeps you can visit a doctor online and
get the medication delivered right to
your home
they make it easy and deliver your
medication every three months
so you don't have to make any extra
trips to the pharmacy keeps treatments
can take four to six months or more to
see results
so the sooner you act the more hair you
can save
find out why keeps has more five star
reviews than any of its competitors and
why
hundreds of thousands of men trust keeps
for their hair loss prevention
medication
go to keeps.com wisecrack or click the
link in the description
to receive 50 off your first order now
back to the show it'd be hugely
disappointing to our philosophically
inclined fans if i didn't mention one of
ancient history's most notable victims
of censorship
in 399 bce a 70 year old man in athens
was sentenced to death on two charges
corrupting the youth and worshipping
false gods the man was socrates and he
was critical of the young democratic
government of athens which was at war
with its neighbor
sparta two of his students were involved
in violent rebellions against athens
while the students died socrates was
still
around to blame the athenians were
worried he'd poison more young minds
with his anti-democratic ideas
so he was put on trial and sentenced to
drink hemlock
when your 10th grade history teacher
brought up socrates it was probably to
show how far
we've come from this kind of censorship
poisoning an old guy for saying stuff is
wrong
today in america we don't punish people
for bad-mouthing the government
it's protected by the first amendment we
can even burn our flag
except well that was a lie and not for
the reasons you think
basically for as long as the first
amendment has existed america has been
incredibly eager to bypass it
indeed our so-called inalienable right
to swear
it's like if there were a book with
covers made you'd think
that's intriguing i wonder what's in
this book that they saw fit to give it
covers made of pure
and then you open it and
was still being decided in the supreme
court as late as the 1970s
but what is censorship anyway broadly
speaking it's the suppression of words
images or ideas that are offensive
harmful or otherwise objectionable to
well whoever the censor happens to be in
the case of socrates the government of
athens censored him because they
believed he was a threat to their
democracy
in its most obvious form the censors are
the people in power
openly trying to stop certain ideas from
reaching the public that might mean
creating laws that let you poison old
guys or
banning and burning books outlawing
religions
nobody expects the spanish inquisition
or even straight up controlling the
press it's the kind of censorship
america's founders feared when they
created the first amendment
prohibiting the government specifically
from limiting speech or establishing a
state religion
sociologist sue curry janssen calls such
limitations
regulative censorship regulative
censorship is hella old
like when egyptian pharaoh ochnaten sent
royal officials to
physically chisel away any references to
gods on tombs
temples and walls that weren't his
preferred god and chinese emperor qin
shi huang
ordered the destruction of books so that
people would believe the world began
with his reign
centuries later in europe the catholic
church published its first index of
forbidden books
then there was the spanish inquisition
which not only prohibited certain books
but expelled jews from spain's borders
torturing and killing thousands of
people in the process
this is the kind of censorship our
history books love to talk about
which isn't a bad thing it's just not
the only thing
over time the kinds of things that got
censored and the way they got censored
started to change
with censorship came more opposition to
censorship
more people started defending freedom of
expression and freedom of the press
globally and those ideas became
particularly popular in europe and its
colonies sweden became the first country
to formally abolish censorship with a
law guaranteeing freedom of the press in
1766
after it finally became a country
america cemented the freedom of the
press and expression in its very first
constitutional amendment
hell yeah censorship oh um
fudge censorship just seven years later
founding father
bill of rights champion and america's
second president john adams signed the
first of the sedition acts which uh
would drag you to court for criticizing
the government oh boy
just like the ancient athenians feared
socrates adams and his fellow
federalists were concerned that their
political opponents were going to spread
anti-government ideas
as a result 25 people were arrested
mostly editors of newspapers who
criticized the adams administration
one guy was arrested for referring to
the prez as the blind bald crippled
toothless queerulous adams
the clear abuse of the law caused
protests across the country and it was
repealed a few years later under
jefferson's presidency
but there would be much more successful
attempted censorship by the government
so we see this open push for censorship
and the ensuing backlash which undoes it
so if you're looking to label some ideas
as unspeakable
what do you do you roll out licenses or
classificatory bodies
for example it's not that you can't say
whatever you want on a tv station but
you do need a
license to run a tv station tonight on
cop drama
on tv they're gonna say
[ __ ] and well to maintain that license
you need to follow the rules laid out by
the fcc
which means not saying certain words
without getting a hefty fine on the
classification front
you can make whatever movie you want but
if it has too many bad words the mpaa
will give it an
r rating and movie theaters won't let
the kids see it sue curry jansen
describes this method as the good lie
which serves to hide the operations of
the censor more often than not
people who aren't specifically
persecuted by the censoring bodies hop
on the bandwagon and accept these new
forms of censorship because such rules
fit with their
world view the licensing kind of
censorship is how woodrow wilson pulled
off one of the most far-reaching
censorship drives in american history
during world war one he formed the
committee on public information
both a creator of propaganda and a
licensing authority
it manipulated and censored all external
news coverage about the war on a scale
never seen before in the u.s
eventually they had control over every
part of the media they reviewed every
newspaper and every radio program to
make sure it didn't impede the war
effort
but instead of the framing of everything
is banned the framing was
the nice authorities are going to look
everything over and to prove it first
the good lie 150 000 americans
emboldened to bolster the war effort
signed up to volunteer for the cpi they
did that stuff
for free wilson also passed the 1918
sedition act
making it punishable by 20 years in jail
to utter
print write or publish any disloyal
profane scurrilous or abusive
language about the form of the
government of the united states
basically a series of laws ensured that
if you printed anything the cpi didn't
approve of you were in big trouble
a guy named charles schenk was sentenced
to six months in prison for distributing
a leaflet opposing the draft with the
headline
long live the constitution of the united
states like socrates teaching
it was dangerous it might jeopardize
america's national security
now you might have heard the phrase
shouting fire in a crowded theater to
describe
reasonable limits on free speech if i
create a fake panic during a play where
people get trampled to death
no one would say that's within your
constitutionally protected rights
it's censorship in a way but a
censorship most reasonable people would
support
but the common sense of the phrase is
hugely deceptive
it became a go-to example of acceptable
censorship after it was lifted from the
text of a supreme court decision for one
mr shank and his anti-draft leaflets but
despite the obviousness of his
logic it was meant as a metaphor for why
shank must be
censored the court unanimously upheld
his conviction criticizing america's
involvement in a war was now akin to
making a false panic at the theater
wilson contended that censorship was
absolutely necessary to public safety
and like the supreme court people bought
it ironically it was wilson's censorship
drive that suppressed news of a
dangerous new form of influenza that was
decimating american military bases while
this censorship was meant to
bolster morale for the war effort nearly
half of troop fatalities were a result
of the center disease
it was this censorship which led to the
name the spanish flu
since spain's press freely reported on
this verboten topic
and this wasn't some weird aberration in
american history
four-time presidential candidate eugene
debs was also thrown in jail for
criticizing the war
and the shank case wasn't overturned
until 1969. as late as 1971 the supreme
court had to decide if wearing a
[ __ ] the draft jacket in a courthouse
was protected speech
while this might seem like bill of
rights 101 it was up for debate among
the nation's foremost legal authorities
if the naughty word in the phrase was
worthy of constitutional protection
a protection the court affirmed in a 5-4
decision
thank god hey no bleeps because it's
history kids
but not all censorship comes from
written laws or court decisions
a lot of it comes from us often
unwittingly
as the result of government interference
according to jansen this is
constitutive censorship other scholars
call it sociological censorship or
existential censorship but it's
basically the set of
unwritten rules and norms that shape and
limit the ideas people have
the censorship that societies allow
tolerate or
even ask for under wilson many papers
actively censored influenza news
just to do their part in the war effort
censoring bad things about the war
effort just became a norm held by people
even without the threat of fines or
imprisonment and its effects continued
long after the war was over constitutive
censorship happens without government's
interference
too for instance i might not want to
show up at the house of former wisecrack
ceo
jacob solomon to leave him a note that
says i am the lizard king
for fear of personal or professional
repercussions
in a survey of 300 journalists by the
columbia journalism review
about one quarter responded that they
purposely avoided newsworthy stories
citing reasons ranging from fear of
embarrassment or potential career damage
to protecting business interest people
also censor themselves with deference to
the sensibilities of others like
not saying curse words around your
parents or not screaming
vaccines are safe and effective in a
whole foods parking lot
for all the points and fingers about
people feeling censored at workplaces or
universities
this is often what's happening groups of
people hold certain values and running
afoul of those values could lead to a
range of reactions from
i respect you less to i'm going to
openly criticize you with my peers for
deviating to
i'm going to try to get you fired in her
history of censorship jansen writes that
constitutive censorships are elastic
limits or permission can be expanded or
contracted but constituent censorships
can never be fully eliminated
what she means is the rules and norms
that define what society finds
acceptable are flexible
and can change sometimes the government
can influence them and sometimes the
public can influence them
but they're always there people often
scream censorship about things that are
kind of inevitable due to this
the same people who think they're being
censored out of fear their peers will
say mean things about them
might very well be the same people
making a 40-minute rage-filled response
video for the crime of suggesting the
last jedi
wasn't that bad with no sense of irony
what they might really be complaining
about though
is the overton window you can imagine
the overton window as a range that
slides
up and down on an ideological spectrum
within the window are a range of ideas
that seem diverse
some are popular and sensible to one
side of the spectrum and the others are
popular and sensible to those on the
other side of the spectrum
but out of view are ideas that are
radical even
unthinkable until they aren't according
to the free market advocate think tank
guy who coined the term
joseph lehmann the window shifts and
moves what was once
unthinkable like say an interracial kiss
on television in the 1960s
might become radical then acceptable and
eventually
even commonplace the window both moves
and widens through exposure to new ideas
because if you force people to consider
an unthinkable idea even if they
don't like it all the less extreme ideas
suddenly seem possible
maybe even acceptable but remember there
are always things
outside the window things beyond public
tolerance
when people argue about cancel culture
and censorship in response to public
figures receiving a torrent of criticism
it's often really a complaint about
where the overton window is
even for the loudest people shouting
free speech on the internet
they probably draw the line like most
people that say
endorsing pedophilia and oftentimes
people as a group
expressing their feelings that such and
such person has bad ideas and is dumb
is itself just people expressing their
own opinions should we
censor those people from criticizing
others this video
gives me this video gives me hope in
certain moments where i'm like this is
actually a pretty good video
and then it gives me brain cancer at the
same time probably not
the point is cries of censorship
directed at one side are often a smoke
screen for saying
my constitutive censorship is normal and
fine yours is not
case in points university professors
getting fired for their ideas
while the narrative is that the
censorious left is getting
anyone fired who doesn't fall in line
with their ideas independent reviews
actually show that while yes this does
happen it happens in
far greater numbers to left-leaning
professors at the hands of conservative
backlash
but back to the overton window there's a
bit of confusion over how it moves
a lot of popular thinking claims that
it's all on corrupt lawmakers who use
their power to intentionally shift the
window to the extreme
whether it's to be inflammatory or make
once fringe ideas more acceptable
and promote their own aims in a politico
interview
lehman argues that this is a
misconception while you can push the
window by advocating for radical ideas
he says it
actually happens through public
discourse he says this idea that
lawmakers are trying to shift the window
is absolutely false
lawmakers are actually in the business
of detecting where the window is
and then moving to be in accordance with
it others like noam chomsky
argue that some lawmakers have an
interest in keeping the overton window
where it is
and that they'll do a whole lot to make
sure people are ignorant of what's
outside of it
in 1998 before the overton window was a
mainstream idea
chomsky argued the smart way to keep
people passive and obedient is to
strictly limit the spectrum of
acceptable opinion but allow
very lively debate within that spectrum
even encourage the more critical and
dissident views
that gives people the sense that there's
free thinking going on through
a lot of channels but especially the
media we hear a lot about what kind of
ideas are radical or crazy that runs
through an elaborate filter of corporate
interests
others have called this kind of
censorship market censorship
basically that while we're giving the
illusion of choice the people who run
the news organizations
publishers and so on get to decide what
is allowed
so while people might be upset when
spotify employees are trying to fire joe
rogan
it's the same kind of editorial decision
making the company employs every day
like when they decide to reject my pitch
for the bring back potatoes the taco
bell podcast or
the spotify should pay musicians more
podcasts brought to you by spotify it's
not that these decisions don't have the
effect of shutting out ideas but it
happens on a daily basis that people are
otherwise fine with
every time a museum opts to show one
artist instead of another every time
someone does or doesn't get a book deal
every time a news anchor's contract is
renewed or not
i'm not saying this kind of market
censorship is good but unless the
argument is
spotify should pay everyone with an idea
with no regard to the content of that
idea
our concept of censorship is a little
lacking here otherwise
it seems like people are saying my ideas
should get past this filter
others should not and while
well-reasoned people are generally
concerned about the way misinformation
spreads on social media like wildfire we
might not want to be so enthusiastic
about twitter removing articles about
hunter biden while coordinated
disinformation
might be a huge threat to the very idea
of free and open discourse
it doesn't take a lot of dot connecting
to see how our methods for fighting
those things can end up haunting us
it might just end up seeding power to
people in capitol hill or silicon valley
to decide what ideas are too dangerous
it's the same rationale that got shank
thrown in jail under wilson
and that blacklisted actors for their
political affiliations during the
mccarthy era in the 1940s and 50s
the federal government thought they had
a solution to a similar problem the fcc
mandated that tv and radio stations gave
air time to both sides of any
controversial issue
it was called the fairness doctrine but
something happened in the early 1960s
john f kennedy figured out he could game
the doctrine by appointing political
allies to the fcc
and then lean on them to find ways to
manipulate news coverage
he told his buddies to rigorously
enforce the fairness doctrine and they
enforced it to be fair
to kennedy by using their fcc powers to
call out any unbalanced
criticisms of him nixon would later do
the same thing
using the fairness doctrine to pressure
tv networks to give more fair and
balanced coverage of the vietnam war
what he really meant was more flattering
coverage and censorship of the war's
atrocities
okay but what does all of this have to
do with big daddy twitter hiding tweets
and
youtube demonetizing videos well a lot
of people are worried that the same
thing the jfk did to the tv networks
could happen with the internet if the
fcc is in the pocket of whoever's in
charge
they might abuse their power and
influence the media we consume
attempting to coerce internet platforms
into widely skewing content moderation
to what governments want seems
maybe bad and also just like another
kind of censorship
ironically pushes by conservative
politicians to be fair to right wing
news outlets ended up with facebook
systematically favoring right wing news
while suppressing left-wing news
facebook brings us to the central
problem with a lot of censorship
discourse
so much of the history of censorship
relates to the government and the
distribution of the press and public
spaces
problem is public space has virtually
disappeared in the last century in lieu
of public squares and meeting places we
have
shopping malls and privately owned
internet companies and
like the taco bell that threw me out
private companies are in no way
obligated to honor free speech laws but
the effect is the same it's just that
instead of the government regulating
speech
companies do censorship today happens in
a myriad of ways
but our narrow focus can often obscure
the greater systems at play
it's easy to get mad when a professor
loses their job it's harder to look at
everyone who never got a job offer and
why
it's easy to get mad at twitter it's
harder to look around and figure out
what kind of public venues for free
speech still
exist and why they've almost all
disappeared and while some may propose a
free market of ideas to duke it out
the free market has always been a
fiction ideas are filtered through so
many levels of market and constitutive
censorship before they can even get
written in a book or put
on the news while we should be on the
lookout for the socrates drinking
hemlock version of censorship
it's just a small part of the picture
it's an incredibly complicated problem
with no
easy solutions and for everyone who's
saying it is maybe take what they say
with a grain of salt
i'll end with scholar michael hulquist
who writes that censorship is impossible
to escape
and that the institutions or legislation
promising free speech
are band-aid solutions he says to be for
or against
censorship as such is to assume a
freedom no one has
censorship is one can only discriminate
among its more and less repressive
effects
so what do you think is censorship
inevitable or should my lifetime ban a
taco bell be
immediately lifted big thanks to our
patrons for all your support
murder that subscribe button like you're
an athenian condemning socrates
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always
thanks for watching later
[Applause]
[Music]
so
you